I will then be ready for your question
that further I do I want you yes you
good thank you very much and thank you
for all coming along this morning this
is obviously a traditional presentation
of our winter forecast for 2019 but also
for 2020 I'm going to tell you about the
five key messages from the winter 29
team forecast first of all the
fundamentals of the European economy
remain robust and sound and should allow
economic activity to continue to grow
this year we're expecting growth to be
positive again once again in all member
states of the European Union in 2019
now one can't hide the fact however that
the growth will slow down to 1.3 percent
in the euro area and will reach 1.6
again in 2020 for the EU as a whole
growth will be slightly stronger 1.5
percent in 2019 and 1.7 percent in 2020
and as you will note we revised our
growth forecast for 2019 downwards by
0.6 points as compared to November now
this was a slowdown which we already
expected back in the autumn but growth
in the eurozone has lost impetus once
again and the course of the second
semester of 2018 now the latest
available figures do actually indicate
that that trend has continued through
into January 2019
now the second lesson we've learnt is
that the fact that the economy is
running out of steam is to a great
extent linked to less support from the
international environment there are
considerable risks there's high levels
of uncertainty Reserve V trade policy
you just look in particular at the US
and China there's a slowdown in
manufacturing industry and these have
led to a slowdown in world trade towards
the end of last year
now given the geographical destinations
for its exports and the specialization
the degree of specialization of the
products this export the euro area the
euro zone has been affected even more by
this slowdown however we can't hide the
fact that this slowdown in the second
semester of 2018 is not just due to
external factors but also due to
internal factors in the major economies
of the eurozone the considerable
slowdown in production of automobiles in
Germany social unrest in France and
finally considerable uncertainty as to
the fiscal policy in Italy now the third
and this is the good news is that
employment is buoyant the number of
people in employment reached the highest
level ever seen in the eurozone and this
positive trend that we've observed on
the European labor market continues
another bit of good news is that this
has resulted in greater wage rises we'll
come on to this later this is good news
because it will feed into household
consumption household consumption should
be the major driver for growth this year
and next year
now the firth mess fourth message is
that inflation in the eurozone went down
at the end of 2018 and due in particular
to considerable drop in energy prices
however as we said there's been a
considerable increase in wages and that
will actually feed into strengthening
underlying inflation the fifth key
message is that there are still
underlying downside risks which are
going to weigh very heavily again this
trimester on our forecast and I'll come
back to that now even if the European
economy has lost impetus in the course
of 2018 you have to remember that this
slowdown has actually followed a very
positive year 2017 Europe saw its
greatest growth levels for ten years in
2017 however recent economic data would
suggest that this slowdown in the
economy of the euro area could last a
little longer than we envisage three
months ago and will and is continuing at
the beginning of 2019 now the European
Commission's confidence indicator was
already on a downward trend since the
beginning of 2018 and it's once again
gone down there's a loss of confidence
among businesses in December of January
across the board through the countries
and sectors and the PMI index for the
euro zone also continued to go down in
January
now this slowdown reflects
to the international environment subject
to a slowdown in world trade as well but
it's also reflected in the internal
factors I've pointed out in the three
major economies of the euro area however
the fundamentals domestically are still
good private consumption will be
affected by a number of factors new
improvements on the labor market an
increase in wage wages increases up
turning wages and lower energy costs
furthermore there are fiscal measures
forecast to be taken by certain member
states and they should support household
purchasing power critically in France I
was thinking investment should continue
to be supported by fairly high rates of
production capacity use and attractive
financial conditions now the year
in central bank intends to continue to
have a very progressive normalization of
its monetary policy and that'll take
account of the economic situation
however of course the slowdown in world
trade could have an impact on business
confidence and and affect investment in
an opposite way and then more negative
way for these reasons we believe that
the temporary factors which have had an
impact on growth over the last few
months should gradually fade in the
course of this year now you might be
surprised if you look at 2019 2020 but
we think there'll be a slight upturn in
the second half of this year
and again a slight acceleration in 2020
and that will actually partly reflect
the number of working days available in
2020
now next port markets and the world
level economic activity has been slowing
down and differentiated manner after
some solid firm growth it's been weaker
growth than expected particularly in the
euro area in Japan and signs of slowdown
in the Chinese economy however economic
growth in the United States in India and
in Asia and the emerging countries in
Asia have been has been very sound
prospects for growth in the world
economy outside the EU have not really
changed compared to our autumn forecasts
in 2019 2020 we're thinking about growth
around 3.8 percent after 3.9% in 2018 so
a slightly lower forecast than we said
in autumn but it just is fairly steady
world imports outside the EU should
increase by 4.8% in 2018 it's gone down
a little bit there was an exceptional
rate of 5.5% in 2017 now here again
we're expecting a new slowdown of world
imports outside the EU and where the
growth of 3.9% the
here and 3.6% next year now as I was
saying the euro area does seem to be
more more affected by the recent
slowdown in it now straight than perhaps
other areas exports growth for the
eurozone actually did weaken throughout
2018 and even a contraction of exports
in the third trimester I can't see the
graph behind me but you'll see that
demand for imports from our trade
partners pretty well stagnated last year
all prices tumbled and investors
concerned but the global incomming
outlook and higher than expected
Iranian all supply also upward price
pressures are expected to be limited by
growing production in the US and in
Canada and also a moderation in global
oil demand as the global economy
gradually shift to a lower gear based on
future markets the average old price in
US dollar terms is assumed to be about
14% lower this year compared to 2018
which is more than significant in Euro
terms the downward revision of all
prices assumptions compared to the
autumn forecast is still most
significant as all prices are now
assumed to be about 20% lower in both 19
and 20 than assumed in the autumn and
this increase in oil prices is said to
provide some support to economic
activity over the forecast horizon
mainly through its impact on households
purchasing power and corporates costs
euro headline inflation rose slightly
above two percent in the third quarter
of 2018 but it dropped considerably
during the last quarter as energy price
inflation quickly adjusted downwards to
falling global
energy prices due to the significant
downward revision in oil prices
assumptions are forecast for Edline
inflation in the euro area in 2019 has
been revised down marketing from 1.8% in
the autumn to 1.4 percent and next year
we expect headline inflation to tick up
mildly to 1.5 percent to only slightly
below our autumn forecasts as far as
core inflation is concerned which
excludes energy and unprocessed food
prices this has been relatively muted
throughout 2018 and it is expected to
rise but only very gradually in 2020 as
favorable light labor market
developments should remain as I said
supportive of solid wage now about
financial markets over the last couple
of months global financial markets
prices have shown high volatility with
investors moving funds from riskier
assets to say for once in the final
weeks of 2018 before regaining some
would say risk appetite that since the
start of this year this move in
sentiment was most likely motivated by
investors reassessment of the underlying
global economic outlook and more dovish
messages from keys and called banks in
the recent weeks easing fears faster
than expected monetary policy
normalization a risk we have highlighted
in the past in Europe sovereign bond
spreads have narrowed against the German
bond reflecting low risk perception
country-specific the factors played
their a major role especially of course
on the Italian debt market as Italian
spreads narrow significantly after
the government put forward amendments to
its draft budget in December so that
shows that basically we made contrary to
what some believe the right decision
there let's imagine what would have
happened if we wouldn't have done that
as I mentioned I moved to the map now in
my introduction we forecast that all EU
member states will continue growing in
2019 though mostly at a slower pace than
in 2018 among the largest economies GDP
growth in 2019 and 2020 is expected to
be at or above the average of 1.5% and
1.7 percent respectively in Poland in
Spain and in Netherlands growth in
Germany is expected but this is not a
surprise because it has been adjusted by
the German authorities themselves to
slow markedly from 1.5 percent last year
to 1.1 percent this year as a result of
weakening export growth and
disappointing private conception growth
despite the buoyant employment situation
factored in the slowdown in the second
half of 2018 were obviously bottlenecks
in an environmental certification in the
automotive sector which led to pronounce
a decline of car purchases looking
forward domestic demand should be
supported by a strong labor market and
some fiscal loosening the higher number
of working days is also set to help
pushing growth to 1.7 percent next year
2020 the same rate at the EU average of
course you cover your inquest Southby we
think in terms of an increase of 1.3
percent in GDP and 1.5 percent in 2020
now this
growth will be particularly buoyed up by
private consumption and that will learn
in itself be supported by fiscal
measures and particularly those which
were adopted at the end of 2018 and it
will also be helped by a drop in energy
prices fell into technical recession in
the second half of last year as the
impact of less dynamic world trade was
compounded by sluggish domestic demand a
particularly investment uncertainty and
a rising financing costs also took their
toll as such growth is now forecast to
be at zero two percent in 2019 and 0.8
percent in 2020 reflecting a slight
pickup in growth as of the second half
of 2019 as well as more working days
next year in Spain GDP growth is
expected to remain above the average
though last markedly than in the
preceding years at 2.1 percent in 2019
and 1.9 percent in 2020 the economic
expansion would also moderate compared
to last year twas 2.5 percent this
moderation is expected to be driven by
slowdown in private consumption with a
view to increase the record though
households saving rates but still as I
said the performance of Spain is above
the EU and eurozone average in the UK
economic activity is expected to have
this rated at the end of last year due
to something that won't surprised you
the height and identity of the UK's
future trading relationship with the EU
GDP growth is expected to remain subdued
this year and next at 1.3 percent
slightly higher than projected in our
auto forecast which could not take into
the fiscal stimulus announced in the
budget but of course as
no since the start of the brexit talks
this forecast is based on the purely
technical assumption of status quo in
terms of trading relations between the
EU and the UK in Greece growth is
forecast to reach 2.2 percent in 2019
and 2.3 2020 so this would be could be
well above the euro area average the
consumer confidence had almost returned
to pre-crisis heights by the end of 2018
and private consumption is likely to
remain a major supporter of growth in
2019
naturally the recovery remains heavily
contingent on the continuing
implementations of reforms that's a
point of course that we are discussing
monitoring in the past programme
civilians process finally growth is some
in some smaller Central and Eastern
European economies is said to remain
partly strong as they benefit from
robust domestic demand fuelled by
dynamic wage growth and the impact of EU
funds finally the youth economy is
facing an exceptional amount of
uncertainty which could weigh as well on
investment and consumption more severely
than currently expected you know that we
always established the balance of risks
and clearly this time the balance moves
to the downside downside risks to the
forecast include following first great
tensions between the US and China have
eased but there is considerable
uncertainty still around the
negotiations between the two second
investors perception on the global
growth outlook could gain to know more
pessimistic and this in turn could
trigger more abrupt corruption than that
can affect the real economy
also many emerging market economies
remain vulnerable to changes in global
risk sentiments third within the your
area the risk of sovereign bank loops
persists even if they seem currently
less pronounced in the context of
generally low sovereign yields finally
our forecast is again prepared under
technical assumption of status quo in
trade relations with the UK a failure to
secure some how smooth proceed would
impact growth more than under the
forecast baseline or though more so in
the UK than in the rest of the EU but
this is not in the forecast because as I
said we moved on technical assumptions
on the upside the still favourable labor
market conditions supplied constraints
in some Member States and the extended
use of the EU budget in recipient
countries who all trigger some
additional domestic demand but you see
that clearly the balances on the
downside to sum up this forecast after
the very strong growth seen in 2017 the
new economy has been decorating and this
is set to continue in 2019 with growth
nonetheless you must always have memory
of the past expecting to reach at 1.5
percent and to be around if general
cross around the EU and the euro area
the slowdown is said to be more
pronounced and expected last autumn
especially in the area for reasons that
I've tried to explain due to global
trade and certainties and also domestic
factors in our largest economies
nonetheless Europe's economic
fundamentals remains solid and we
continue to see good news particularly
on the job front which is of course
something which is absolutely decisive
for EU citizens and we expect growth to
rebound gradually the second half of
this year and in 2020
what Ali principal massage so those are
the key messages and of course I'm very
happy to take your questions now
very much commissioner like you said
ready for your question how about we
start with Maria
let's give it a second it'll come
you
good morning my ribs are open TV carries
a question on Greece if I may there are
some good news and although your
predictions in general about the years
are not optimistic for Greece you
predict a port and your previous
predictions why is that and is there any
risk during this procedure
Thank You Greece it's clear is one of
the rare countries where the forecast
has been revised slightly and upwards
the often forecast in the winter interim
forecasts are not directly competitive
comparable in the case of Greece this is
because I'm hot on forecasts for 2019
and 2020 was based on the technical
assumption of a new policy change in
fiscal policy since the cutoff date of
the auto forecast the expansionary
fiscal package incorporated in 2019
budget was not yet finalized and this
technical assumption also had
implications for the macroeconomic
outlook the technical assumption of
tighter fiscal policy lead to lower
consumption and those just lower growth
the autumn forecast does projected that
flat 2 percent growth for 2018 19 to 20
and we are now obviously more ambitious
instead our current forecast and this
reflects the fact that which is now
fully in the European semester is
comparable and in line with the
forecasts already published in November
in the firsthand and civilians report
I've been as you know in Athens quite
recently I was invited by the Frank
Olynyk Chamber of Commerce at the
occasion to meet a lot of people from
the business and this is clearly
reflected also in the micro economic
sentiment of the actors so let's hope
that it confirms
and so a question in the back Petra
you
Oh Commissioner Peter from Villiers
thought Slovenia News Agency my question
is about the Slovenian draft budgetary
plan you received some additional
clarifications on Monday from the
civilian authorities I would just like
to know if you are satisfied with them
and when can we expect your final
assessment thank you as you said
Slovenia submitted an updated draft
particular plan on the 25th of January
following the submission of its initial
no policy change plan in October 2018 we
are currently assessing of this updated
EBP including the response received from
the sublinear authorities to the letter
sent by qu booty on the 30th of January
which asked the Slovenian authorities to
provide further information on the
precise composition of the planned
structural effort and expenditure
developments and we will adopt an
opinion on this updated DBP plan in due
course
I mean can't from the Financial Times a
question about Italy you said that the
Commission made the right decision in
December and one of the reasonings
behind your decision was that you
thought that the Italians own growth
forecasts were becoming a bit more
realistic
so they're macroeconomic projections
were a bit more realistic
I think the Italian Prime Minister today
said that he's going to stick by rooms
own version of what Italian growth would
be so how do you explain the discrepancy
between where you are with growth in
well where the Italians say they are and
given this gap does it effectively mean
that the two point not 4% budget deficit
target is completely unrealistic for
this year given that we're going to have
faltering growth
well forecast what they are forecast not
yet but as you said I was in France with
something we call the last lap re-sod
which is a whole lot of evidence they
are where they are we are where we are
and other interest or international
institutions are where they are and you
can then consider what the portrait of
forecast is all around concerning the 1%
projection underpinning the December
agreement
I must recall you that this was the Bank
of Italy's forecast which was deemed
credible by Italy's Parliamentary Budget
Office has fallen under the new fiscal
framework that it was also more or less
consensus of the economists and based on
the information we had at that time it
looked credible also to the Commission
and it look credible and we say to
almost everybody
as for the budget agreement let me
record that this came at a time of
significant uncertainty on future
policies in Italy which had resulted in
high market volatility and rising
sovereign yields and you saw that the
agreement we reached helped in
alleviating market tensions as shown by
the sizeable the
sovereign yields and this is why I
repeat that without the budget agreement
concluded in December the situation
would have probably been worse and I
couldn't even say much was Italy slowed
down set in already in the first half of
2018 amid the easing in euro area growth
and concerns about global trade
it was amplified in the second half of
2018 by uncertainty about domestic
policies which led to rising servant
kneels and first signs of tightening
friends in conditions for the private
sector and nonetheless economic
indicators since December have all been
negative and this had to be reflected in
our new forecast that I think please
solid and realistic and to ensure that
the rest of the question of going food
the Commission will continue to closely
monitor the economic and fiscal
developments in Italy as you know now
we've got four forecasts a year and
among those four forecasts - just based
on gross projections and the two others
include fiscal developments at the
beginning of the semester and the end of
the semester now we are in the SE
intermediate evaluation the next
important step will be the publication
of the country report at the end of
February and the assessment of Italy's
fiscal position with respect to
requirements of the stability and growth
pact in spring so we are clearly in the
monitoring process and we will go on
discussing with the Italian authorities
to see what kind of future we need to
define together
you
we were seeded correct ready ready
Callahan Italian shot the follow-up pop
oh just a follow-up on the future
Anthony are you excluding any
intervention before spring in other
words before the June deadline of
following the EP elections or the end of
May when you were going to be issuing
your opinion on the stability plan for
the coming year so that was my first
question then a second question on your
evaluation of the situation do you think
that the Italian government's fiscal
measures will boost growth or as Olivier
Blanchard in a recent article well they
have an effect which will push Italy
into recession
we shall of course respect the various
deadlines are within the European
semester
not because we're overly formalistic in
our approach but simply because it is
only when we have data about the
previous years and for the details for
coming years that we can do anything
there is little reason in being over
precipitous so we are going to continue
working on a solid earth pushing as we
have always done now of course you have
raised a theoretical point but I think
that the facts do speak for themselves
at any rate I do not think that the
Keynesian expansion which had been
announced is really on the the cards
however having said that an improvement
in the spreads and the financial
situation might be forthcoming but that
should give us some food for thought
you
we kiss chunky this is a question which
is in a way linked to the previous one
but this is on France if I've understood
you correctly for France you're saying
that the budget or expenditure announced
towards the end of the year would have a
positive effect on growth is this
another way of saying that you might be
overshooting they might be over shooting
or infringing European rules temporarily
and that that would be a good thing for
economic growth and how do you reconcile
that with Italy where uncertainty has
perhaps had an opposite effect and might
be leading in towards recession
well since the very beginning I've
refused to make any sort of comparison
between the two situations they're not
things you can compare in fiscal and
budgetary terms and I've seen some
comments in the French press and even
your own newspaper mr. Chris young don't
know what you think I'm going to say but
basically I have to base myself on the
rules and the rules are pretty precise
you cannot have a lengthy overshoot
which was the initial suggestion from
Italy you do have to respect the rules
on the structural deficit and we do have
to take account of the debt and the debt
levels and France and Italy are not in
the same situation at all these measures
that have been announced could overshoot
the 3% that would be enshrined would be
okay under the rules if it's very
temporary and as long as they come back
under 3% by 2020 so you can't make a
comparison between the two and you can't
compare measures which are not taken
against the same background or not of
the same nature with a completely
different fiscal situation in the two
countries I would just like to repeat
that the forecasts that we've given
today are strictly economic we're not
talking about the impact of public
finances that's something we have to
assess later and what I've talked about
today applies to all countries in the
euro area of course so from an economic
point of view purely in the short term
these expansionist budget fiscal
measures will have an effect on growth
we believe and this is what we're
measuring we're looking at short term
long term fiscal stability budget
instability and this is all part of the
package I settled on do you mind my keys
to impress Cousteau ma or perhaps my my
question shanty I'm over here
I hope my question is not an opportune
but I would like to find out whether
Spain will be in a position to meet its
commitments with this forecast growth
trend perhaps you could expand on how
you see the situation and are you aware
this a tendency of growth are going down
when you gave the go-ahead to the draft
budget well to be quite frank with you
we're not speaking about public finances
here today I'm not
saying that this has no impact on public
finances or nor that we will not be
discussing this at some point in the
future which we shall do when the time
is good and right so I think you have to
mitigate but I'm going to have to say in
that light too however the forecasts for
Spain very low and 2.21 percent which is
the Spanish level does it signify
slowdown up when compared with previous
years but nonetheless this is a level
which is considerably above the average
for the eurozone in the case of France
the slogan is also moderate but we're
still at the average level for the EU
and the eurozone
hi natural come from from a confidential
you said there are some risk for the
Spanish focus like for example increase
uncertainty both domestic and external I
would like to know if it is possible to
elaborate a bit more on the domestic
uncertainty for for Spain should
remember everything rules occur
could I just repeat something if you
compare this with our autumn forecast
which were published back in November
it's true that we've revised growth
downwards but by 0.1 of GDP so that's
less than the whole of the euro area and
less than the whole of Europe
but there is a general consideration
here it's a bit less of a contribution
from export to growth than we'd expected
when we forecast things back in the
autumn so I don't think we should draw
any more serious conclusions than that
it's more or less stable there is a bit
of a downturn at the moment of course
there's always a space for conjecture
but there are other countries where I
think you could have a little bit more
conjecture and in the situation in which
they find themselves
thank you very much and rescued from
Spanish mmediately re-open to us I would
like to I would like to ask you about
again about the Spain this forecast is
considering the the new budget the
current budget the future budget I mean
how are you doing this forecast when we
didn't know what budget would be in
Spain next year and this year natural
money if you continue on this path we do
of course I would prefer to have a
budget in Spain and that's what we are
expecting having said that this is not a
unique situation and this is a situation
which has occurred on previous occasions
and we have made a growth forecast in
that context so let me just repeat once
again at that public finance questions
will be discussed at a later juncture
and I will return it to them then for
all US and country much commissioner I'm
afraid that's all we have time for today
we have our experts in the room who will
be able to help you with technical
background
you